brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are inshallah before i
start wanting to let you guys know
inshallah i am trying to raise 500 000
meals for muslim aid please please guys
go to the link and give these people are
starving imagine you help them have
iftar and sisters imagine the reward
that you will get do check that out in
the link in the description box below
inshallah we're going to get straight
into this video
there's a new brand on the scene called
alif they make 100 halal raw cat food
there are countless health benefits to
this new raw diet check them out on
instagram at lift.uk they do monthly
subscription boxes and you can get 10
discount on their two week trial box
with my code ali10 check them out now
and let your cat enjoy some nice food
this video is the pinnacle of insanity i
mean i don't even know what to say when
i saw this i was absolutely gobsmacked i
could not believe that
a dead body of a rapper or whoever it
may be or any anybody for that matter is
in a nightclub
made to stand in a certain way and
people are clubbing they're dancing
they're enjoying their self like this is
something normal let's go to this video
on mute and let's see for ourselves the
shocking moments of a dead body in a
club to remember
him
let's see for ourselves
now you guys saw that for yourselves
sisters and it i had to watch that again
and i was like is this for real i saw
something similar to this but it was in
a night club yeah and it was they had a
dead body sitting like this you know
eyes open something like that you know
just to remember him or in his memory
whatever it may be but this guy is in a
nightclub now why does this occur guys
because of jahilia ignorance
because this shows us how important
religion is when you don't have a
religion you make your things up as you
go you don't know what is good or bad
anymore
it is crazy guys
i want to give you guys a perspective of
islam how islam deals with a deceased
person
compared to what people are doing these
days
i mean
literally burning them you know to ashes
um you know or you know burning
like i don't know what else they do
these days you know like
get bring them to a nightclub whatever
it may be in islam when a person dies
firstly
we say that indeed we come we came from
allah and indeed to him we shall return
we remind ourselves and remind people
around us that this is going to be our
end number one
number two we give ut most respect to
the deceased
utmost respect
that when their body is laid
yes
in a mosque he is washed
or she is washed cleaned respectfully
gently with utmost
humility and respect and honor to the
body we don't just throw it away throw
it away but i'll just burn it
utmost respect with prayers
yes
we let the family
see the deceased
we let
them pray for him
you know
we then cover it with white shroud
and then we take the dead body to its
burial site while proclaiming god
almighty's purity
and praising him as a reminder for us
and then when we take him to be buried
we carry on this liquor yes
okay
there's different things that you can
say
and then you be you bury him gently
yeah you gently bury him you face his
body towards the qibla
the direction that we face to worship
god almighty
and then you put planks
and then you bury him and then you pray
for him
and you try to pray for him in his this
life in the hereafter you ask if anybody
if he owed anybody debt because owing
debt and dying on debt is a very major
sin that the prophet muhammad peace be
upon him refused burial of a certain
person because he had debt you know so
it's very important that people go and
ask does he owe anybody money because
when they correct this effect because he
can't do it himself they want to
they want to correct this effect in this
life so
what they correct here would inshallah
correct them there
they are literally taking care of his
dunya and his
but sadly when you look at this person
you know and and also like we do like
stuff like called
which is an ongoing deed which could be
building the school or whatever it may
be given in his name you know his kids
can be a form of sadaqa for him it's a
form of giving you know that he benefits
in the hereafter doing the school in his
name or water world a mosque that has
people enter that mosque god learn in
that school or drink from that water
that he benefits in the hereafter
now let's compare that to what we saw of
a person who is deceased these people
give him no benefit in this life no one
is hereafter they are partying like
something good has happened they have
brought his deceased body
to a club
they have brought him they are bringing
him no benefit in his hereafter
not in this life and it just seems that
they just don't really care if he died
it's just a moment just celebrating
i mean look at the beauty of islam
this person who passed away
you know i do not mean any disrespect
to him
or his family i'm just shocked at what
this group of people have decided to do
which is really disturbing
i mean i don't want to long the video
out that's all i had to say to compare
it and alhamdulillah for islam
alhamdulillah that we have a way of life
that
you know put almost utmost respect on
those who are alive and those who have
died
that's all i have to say about my
sisters may allah bless you guys
share this video you know with your
friends and family and maybe your
non-muslim friends so they can see you
know how islam honors and dignifies a
deceased person
and subhanallah may allah correct our
affairs
before we die inshaallah till next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh